[Music]
hey there youtube thanks for coming to
chess openings explained i'm nick risco
your instructor for the night and
tonight our opening of choice is going
to be the terrace variation
of the french defense so hello everybody
i've got the youtube chat pulled up here
gonna be taking questions as we go
if you have a question just put it in
try to get to it as soon as i can so
let's jump right into it
okay so we're going to start off here
with one e4
and pawn to e6 and this is the french
defense and the most common move here is
pawn to d4
if your opponent is going to give you
the center you might as well
take it and the idea of e6 is so black
can go pawn to d5 and also fight for the
center
and here there's a few different moves
white can play
white can end up pushing and go into the
advanced french
they can go knight c3 for the classical
systems
they can annoy everybody and take on d5
and go into a boring french exchange
or they have the move we're going to
cover tonight which is knight to d2
which has
probably less theory than all the other
lines but still very fun to play
the ideas can be easier to grasp and
the main reason people would go knight
to d2
is to avoid the the winower french which
is after knight c3 bishop to b4
black has this very annoying pin that
normally forces white to double up their
c
pawns and uh get get some good
initiative on the queen side
so we're going to start with knight to
d2 and we're going to take a look at
some of the different moves black has
here
let's see let's scroll down in my notes
here there are one two
three four five different moves here i
guess we'll start off
with pond a6 and this is
the modern system we're going to cover
some of the uh
smaller sidelines let me turn off these
annotations real quick
so a6 the modern system
normally we'll see white just play
normally with normal development knight
g
to f3 and black will strike in the
center with c5 and this
this uh c5 push is going to be very
common from black we're going to be
seeing this in most variations
and here white takes on d5
and the pawn will recapture and here
white can take on c5 and give black this
isolated queen's pawn
so normally this would be a disadvantage
for black but it's you know too early in
the game there's so many pieces on the
board
it's hard to tell if this is going to be
an advantage or disadvantage
we're going to go knight to b3 just hit
this bishop
the bishop has to move to safety so it
goes to b6
white's going to continue with regular
development
all the way down bishop to g5
trying to get black to trade the queens
and once they do
king takes is fine with the queens off
the board in this open position
having the king out in the center isn't
isn't too bad
uh bishop to g4 looking to possibly take
on f3
rook h to e1 and now the king is ready
to drop back to f1 with
check knight g to e7 to block this idea
of the check
and this position is pretty balanced for
both sides blacks are going to have to
watch out for this
isolated queen's pawn being a target in
the future but that's going to be
a little ways down the road
we also have back on move three
uh grimards line so i mentioned this um
i think it's a week or two ago when i
did my nimsovich
lecture um where in the nimsovich
defense you can end up transposing to
this opening here so knight c6
definitely has some surprise factor
behind it
normally like i said black is going to
be going for this c5 push but here after
knight to c6
that's no longer possible so what are
black's ideas here
well after knight to f3 they go knight
f6
and we see pawn to e5 and knight to d7
those moves there are pretty standard
for for french openings
now we see knight to b3 just reinforcing
d4
opening the line up for our bishop
we'll see normally pawn to a5
they can also go bishop e7 and then
after bishop b5
there's a5 and a4 but this transposes
right
into the main line where after
bishop to b5 there's normally going to
be knight a7
with the idea that you know you're
hitting the bishop
you don't want white to be able to take
and double up the pawns
so we'll see bishop to d3 not wanting to
have to
open up the a file too early or give up
bishop pair
b6 just solidifying the pawn
and after it castles there is pawn to c5
pawn to c4
both sides are trying to fight for the
center adding a lot of tension
bishop to b7 queen to e2 some more
standard development from both sides
these moves should be pretty natural
rook d1 being prepared for any opening
on the files
you'll see knight c6 bringing it back to
the center cd5 ed5
and here the position again is pretty
equal white
pretty much just has that first move
advantage
uh so that is the gist of the green mars
line i see a lot of people saying uh
you know we're not going over more of
the critical moves
but that's just because these are more
of the sidelines i want to make sure we
can focus on
the main lines here in this opening
okay aside from knight 2 c6
there is also bishop to e7 also having a
little bit of surprise factor behind it
because normally black is going to try
and go c5 or knight f6
uh you normally don't see bishop e7 this
early and this is the mirezovich
defense here we will see white continue
with the normal knight g to f3 knight f6
again we see the e5 and knight d7 moves
and bishop to d3 we're noticing that
this bishop is coming to d3 a lot
the knight that's on f6 is being kicked
by the pawn and going to d7 a lot so
these are going to be common ideas
throughout the rest of the night
and here we will see black go pawn to c5
and pawn to c3 just to solidify in the
center
now if black takes white can recapture
with the pawn maintaining strong center
knight two c7 castles and this is going
to be very similar to the main line
we're going to discuss tonight but the
difference between
this and what we're going to go over
later is the knight is on e2
instead of f3 and now we see both sides
fight for space on the queen side
a5 a4 castles by black
rookie won by white uh takes in the
center
knight b4 coming in hitting the bishop
you just move that bishop back
to b1 you don't really want to go to c2
and allow black just to trade here
because this light square bishop is one
of white's better pieces
you don't want to keep the dark square
bishop when your dart or when your pawns
are on the dark squares in the center
you want to keep that light square
bishop keep up the attack
so that's why you go all the way back to
b1
and now the knight really doesn't have a
purpose here on b4 so we'll see black
move it back towards the center try to
regroup and white does have an edge here
just because it's kind of hard to see
where black is supposed to pile up
but this is also a way to play if you're
looking for some surprise factor white
may not be prepped here
uh is the black king in danger uh
yes so uh black may need to watch out
for some greek gifts
here but uh i believe with the bishop on
e7 and queen on d8 behind it
there should be enough enough pieces on
g5 to stop some of these
but yeah after like knight f1 maybe
knight g3
black may need to worry about some greek
gift sacrifices but
here they they don't work out just
because g5 is protected
okay uh all right so after
looking at the morezovich defense we
will go back
let's see a big sideline
is pawn takes on e4 this one gives
black really good chances this
transposes to the rubenstein french
after knight takes e4 and i feel like
that opening kind of deserves its own
course maybe in the future we'll do a
chess openings
abridged for it but um i feel like that
one just has too much in it for us to
fully cover tonight so we won't go over
pawn takes and that leaves us
with the two main moves here
after knight to d2 there are two
different uh ways black can play
other than all those sidelines we just
looked at there
is pawn to c5 and there is knight to
f6 so first we will look at pawn to c5
which is an open system
for black this position does normally
open up
for both players and can lead to some
very sharp
positions and actually both of these
moves c5
c5 and knight to f6 both lead to
sharper positions so after
pawn to c5 uh let's see white has
two different ways they can play we'll
start off looking at um
well we've been playing knight f3 a lot
for the for the sidelines so
we have knight g to f3
and now here black can either play um
c takes d4 which we will continue with
in just a second or they can play
knight to f6 and this will transpose
into the
uh yeah the mirazovic variation we just
took a look at
so i'll just show the transposition here
and you'll notice we end up in the same
exact position
where the knight is on f3 bishop is on
d3 this bishop's on e7
where white will have that slight edge
but the way black should probably play
this is
c takes d4 and now white will take on d4
right away with their knight
that can go to f6 putting pressure on
the pawn on e4
and instead of protecting it with
something like bishop to d3
white does better just by trading it off
the board queen takes
and now knight to b5 don't worry it is
protected by the bishop
and it's getting ready to go to see c7
where there's this
monster fork with the queen
king and rook so black needs to defend
against this
what better than knight a6 now we see
knight to c3 the knight isn't really
going to
to have a shot at landing on c7 anymore
so it just comes back to c3 getting a
tempo off the queen
and once the queen drops back to d8 we
have something like
pawn to a3 stopping black's pieces from
coming to b4
so we'll see bishop e7 black's got a
castle
queen to f3 probably putting some
pressure on b7 here
might be looking to slide over to g3 in
the future
we see a knight to c7 just bringing it
towards the center
bishop to d3 uh and here we will see
knight
c to d5 again just moving it towards the
center
and instead of trading the knights this
trade is probably not going to be
beneficial
to white after queen takes they're
offering a queen trade it's hard to see
how white gets an edge here with this
knight on d2
so instead of trading off the knights
and having that knight on d2 stuck there
we usually see um sorry not that night
we see the knight on
d2 come up to e4 getting ready to
recapture on c3
or the knight on c3 capturing on e4
normally there's the the capture on e4
i know i just said the knight but white
does better taking with the bishop here
putting pressure on this diagonal and we
see a trade
bishop f6 hitting the queen and queen f3
here pretty equal position black's gonna
have to worry about a little bit of
pressure on b7 but not too much other
than that
both sides will enjoy an open board with
bishop pairs
okay so that covers
the knight to f3
now the main way white plays this i
think the most popular move is e takes
d5 and this can lead to
some very sharp positions after queen
takes
queen takes d5 is the critical line
there's also e takes d5 but after e
takes d5
i think some natural development for
both sides should just lead
to an equal position where black will
have this isolated queens pawn and it's
going to remind us of
some of the i believe is the modern
variation that we looked at earlier
but we'll look at queen takes d5 because
this is the
critical line we see knight to f3
this is very common c takes d4
and we temporarily give up this pawn we
will get it back
very shortly we go bishop c4 first
instead of probably another natural move
is knight to b3 looking to get at it
right away
but it's better to go bishop c4 getting
ready to castle
and hitting the queen first because you
can go knight b3 in the future
the queen normally goes to d6 and after
castles
knight f6 now we will see the move
knight to b3
uh here knight to c6 to defend the pawn
is normally played but it should be
noted
black cannot go to e5 this is a big
mistake
and probably one of the the cleanest
ways to take advantage of this
is starting with rook to e1 black has
made a lot of queen moves they've made a
lot of pawn moves so their king has not
castled yet
so tactics do exist you just put the
rook on the e-file
it pins this pawn so it's not really
protecting d4
and let's just see what happens if black
tries to defend
they can go knight c6 trying to defend
but again because this pawn is pinned we
can just keep adding more and more
attackers
so the move bishop f4 is possible here
getting ready to capture now let's say
black keeps trying to defend with knight
d7
well here the move knight to g5
might look strange at first but you're
just threatening to take on f7 and
win some material let's say they go
knight to d8 to defend against this fork
after knight to d8 you know this knight
was protecting
d4 but now that it has moved d4 is
falling so
after knight takes bishop to e7
you know you don't really want to uh try
and take with the queen
you're going to lose it so we see bishop
to e7 and now knight 2
f5 is going to trade off more pieces
white is going to have a very strong
initiative here
so we see like a queen trade and rook d1
and let's say black is careless and
takes on f4 they're already facing mate
with rook to e7 and after a couple
forcing moves here
we will see that it is going to be mate
with two knights and a rook
now e takes f4 is not the best move but
you know that's that's if black is being
careless
um but this position here is already
like plus four
um plus four and a half just because
white has this initiative and black's
just wasted the time and not castled
so again e5 terrible blunder
can't do it you have to go knight c6 if
you're trying to hold on
and here we'll just see the knights
trade we'll see knight takes d4
uh better to go with the queen side
knight
takes and takes now we open up the king
side
for the queen in the future if we so
desire
pawn to a6 now this is stopping any
knight to b5 ideas that we saw earlier
with the knight going to c7
it's also stopping any bishop checks and
they're probably getting ready to play
pawn to b5 just kicking the bishop away
we see rook to e1 just getting on the
half open file
very nice development here queen to c7
hitting the bishop we have to protect it
so we just drop it back to b3
now black is finally getting some of
that time to develop after bishop d6
there is a threat
on h2 so we will see pawn to h3 just
moving it out of the way
no need to worry about it and now
castles
after castles this position is pretty
even i'll give a few more moves here
and i really don't know what my personal
evaluation of of this line is
after bishop to g5 looking to capture
and double the pawns
open up the king side black does like to
insert this bishop h2 check
and force the king to the corner i'm not
really sure why this is necessary i'm
just going to be honest with you guys i
don't completely understand it but
probably just going bishop f4
looking for this trade of bishops now
again white put the bishop on g5 looking
to capture on f6
so they capture on f6 instead of on f4
they they do want to double up black
spawns
and now after something like queen h5
king h8 this position um all the
computers i've checked with
are saying it's equal the theory says
it's equal i find this position to be
rather
unclear for both sides
so if there's anyone watching who has
more experience in these kinds
excuse me in these kinds of positions
feel free to drop it in the comments
section below
once this is uploaded to youtube but
this is probably the most critical line
in the open variation
it looks like that should cover most of
the open system lines i don't
think i'm forgetting anything here
uh so we're going to move on into
the was it the closed system
with knight to f6
see knight to f6 so the move here
white just goes pawn to e5
again we've seen this move a lot tonight
this is going to be very common
when the knight goes to f6 you just play
pawn to e5
hit that knight force it to go to d7
white has the move bishop to d3 just
developing on the diagonal again
this is probably the most natural square
in the terrace
and we see black hit with c5
now the point of developing the knight
to d2
this does not transpose to the advanced
variation
and the reason is because the bishop is
already on d3 and the advanced variation
that's not always clear
and in the advanced variation you'll
normally see white put the knight on f3
where here in the main line of the
closed system we're going to look at
knight to e2
so a few little subtleties here
between the terrace and the advance but
we do
see pawn to c3 defending d4 with the
same idea
as the french advance
knight to c6 again very common french
idea
hitting the pawn on d4 and here
really comes the main difference between
the tarash and something like the
advance
is we have this move knight to e2 which
may seem
very very strange at first
it's not very often we see the knight
just go to e2 in our king's pawn opening
normally that knight goes on to f3
but here
the idea is that with d4 being attacked
you want to be able to bring the knight
on d2 to f3 that way you can get
another defender on d4 you can't you
know bring it to b3 to defend because
you'll run into pawn c4
forking the knight and bishop so we go
knight e2
for probably the sole purpose of just
bringing the other knight to f3
i will back it up one move here though
there is another way that black can try
playing this
is pawn to b6 now this one's a little
bit more dubious
still looks completely playable where
they just go b6
and try and uh you know if white ever
captures for some reason they can
recapture with pawn
and try and go bishop to b7 i feel like
black's light square bishop gets
misplaced here but when you're playing
the french
you know your light square bishop is
crying most of the time because it's
shut in so this is at least an attempt
to try and improve it we will see knight
to e2 again
just developing getting ready to castle
bishop to a6
which is a nice move by black so like i
said this light square bishop normally
struggles in the french
here black is making an effort to trade
it off
so bishop a6 knight a6 and castles will
leave white
with a happy king and knight to c7
may be trying to go to b5 in the future
it's hard to tell where this knight is
going to go really
knight to f4 just putting some pressure
on probably e6 there are some
some variations where if black is
careless the knight can sacrifice itself
on e6 but here it will not work because
the knight also supports
and here there's two moves by by black
black could opt
to try and keep it closed with something
like pawn to c4
but queen to g4 will leave white with a
little bit of pressure on the king side
making it harder for the uh black to
develop
so they're gonna have to go something
like b5 and after b3 go
g6 just to uh keep their um
pieces from being attacked and try and
go for this queen side push
um again so just like last week people
are suggesting moves in the chat
i am seeing them but please try and have
a move number
and a variation that it's in it'll make
it a lot easier for me to answer you
guys's questions
so we'll look at bishop to e7 here
instead of pawn to c4
they leave the tension in the center
again queen to g4 hitting g7
pawn to g6 is going to save the pawn and
knight to f3 and this knight is going to
probably go to g5 put some pressure
can't go right now obviously because of
the queen and bishop
but just a couple ideas for the future
uh in here black can either play pawn to
c4 again trying to shut it down but
white gets a pretty strong attack after
h4 and if they go b5
trying to break it's just a little too
slow this knight comes to e2
and now the knight on f3 is getting
ready to jump into g5
uh the other option for black is to try
and go h5 and hit the queen
this is more active probably a bit
better um queen to h3
pawn to c4 now shutting it down but the
idea is you've misplaced the queen
not really helping out on g5 anymore so
now you can go
um have some more play on the queen side
white will go a4
to stop the idea of b5 black goes pawn
to a5 and now we might get
pawn to g4 trying to break through
black cannot take because it will hang
the rook
with a crushing crushing position so
you'll normally see
h4 um and this will be
your starting position but white does
have a significant advantage here
okay um someone was asking
about bishop to c2
instead of taking on a6 here which is
a very good comment after bishop to
to c2 there is knight to c6
uh which has to be considered looking at
this position
um it kind of seems that black's bishop
actually
has a purpose on this diagonal um
and with the knight coming to c6 i kind
of feel like we missed our opportunity
to misplace black's pieces
once we capture on a6 and the knight
recaptures
the knight cannot come forward so it has
to go back to reposition
and i feel like this may just be the
reason why they take
um why they take on a6
just so that way this knight is a little
misplaced black has to spend that
extra move or two to put this knight in
a better spot
okay
let's go back to the main position so
again b6 was just a sideline but
knight c6 is the main move here putting
pressure on d4 and we see knight to e2
after knight to e2 normally we will see
black take on d4 why exactly this moment
again i'm not entirely sure why this is
the exact moment
but i know black is wanting to get this
bishop out and castle soon
at least after the trade then
it's not like white is ever going to
have any ideas of taking although that
may not be wise anyway because the pawn
on e5 is weak so again
another position where you know if you
know exactly why on this move
feel free to drop it down in the
comments
so c takes d4 c takes d4 you're not
wanting to capture with the knight very
important because after knight takes
there is knight takes e5 and you hang
this center pawn
and now white does have the space to
start maneuvering their pieces
so cannot take with the knight you have
to take with the pawn
and this was the entire idea of playing
knight d2 was that way you could play
pawn c3 and recapture with the pawn
and here again a couple more
alternatives for black the main move
here is pawn to f6 which we will look at
in just a second
but i do want to mention queen to b6
queen to b6 is another move that's very
popular in the french
with the idea of hitting d4
and yeah queen b6 seen a lot in the
french advance
hitting d4 what are we going to do about
it well this is why
our knight went to e2 earlier was so
that way after something like queen b6
the other knight can go to f3 and you
have d4
completely defended by your knights your
dark square bishop doesn't need to worry
about coming to defend the center and
giving up b2
because your knights are all over it now
if you
see pawn to f6 there's a capture capture
castles bishop to d6 an active square
for the bishop
and now normally white will play knight
to c3 here black will castle
bishop to e3 now this pawn if black
decides to take it
is poison because of knight to b5
hitting the bishop and then you're also
looking to go
maybe rook to to b1 here so if they go
like bishop to b8
saving it there's rook b1 queen to a2
rook to a1 queen to b2 and you can just
shuffle back and forth at least got to
draw this way if you're not looking for
the draw then
rook to a4 is a move suggested by the
engine it's a little
a move that's a little bit out there but
the idea is bishop
to c1 just hitting this queen more and
more
so they cannot take on b2 it is poison
just because the queen
is likely going to be trapped so instead
of going for the pawn
we will see bishop to d7 looking for
development
pawn to a3 just stopping the knight from
coming in and hitting our bishop
see bishop to e8 looking to possibly
reroute to g6 or f7
maybe trying to open up the d7 square
for our knight
we'll see knight to g5 hitting the weak
pawn
and knight to e7 here
so we are leaving this position with the
pawn hanging
so we should always ask ourselves what
if white takes
well if white takes this hanging pawn
black has the tactic bishop takes h2
king takes h2 queen takes e6
where black kind of opens up the
position a little bit
and it gets a lot of space under control
on the king's side
trying to get the queen into the game
this gives black quite a bit of activity
so i would not recommend white taking
this pawn
on e6
instead just normal normal moves like
rookie one are going to be fine putting
it on this
file once this bishop moves
either you know d2 moving it back maybe
it'll somehow get traded off on f4
then there's going to be more pressure
on e6 you want to just keep it as a
target for the long term
okay so that is queen to b6 and i will
also note that this queen b6 idea can
also be played
later on and transposed right back into
those lines we just looked at
um i believe it was specifically on move
11. so i will point that
out again in just a second when we get
there
back to the main line pawn to f6
this is a break known in the in the
french where
if you can't attack at the base of the
pawn chain you attack at the head of the
pawn chain
and here black is just trying to to ruin
white's center structure
so it would be best for white just to
take with
the pawn to
do there is a sideline here but i think
i'm going to save that for the very
end um so after
pawn takes knight takes knight to f3
just um opening up the path for the
bishop protecting the pawn
bishop to d6 castles
and uh like i said i'll call it out
queen to b6 is playable here this will
transpose into the line where white just
plays knight to c3
okay i see a lot of people quoting ben
feingold here
don't play f6 but here f6 is completely
fine the
diagonal to check the king is blocked
off by the knights
is f4 a line f4 is a line actually
um i think i don't know if it's here
in this position but there are ideas of
white playing f4
i just didn't cover those in this
lecture tonight because we do have some
some other sidelines that i wanted to
look at that are probably more critical
and i think white has better chances
without playing f4
but yes charles smith f4 is an idea in
some of these lines
okay we go back to castles like i said
here queen b6 is a move
uh the other sideline here is queen to
c7
putting some pressure on h2 if you're
not careful with this knight
you may lose a pawn but there's no
worries for white
he's go bishop to g5 getting that bishop
off of the back row this rook may come
to c1 in the future
we'll see black castle bishop to h4 just
jumping ahead of any
you know pawn h6 ideas and now
white or sorry black can play either
knight
h5 and we see like queen c2
h6 uh bishop check and come back
there's actually a couple moves going on
here there's a thematic sacrifice
so i should also note this taking on f3
is a move
very thematic in the torah for black in
the closed systems
in some lines as early as move 14
um and bishop h5 rook f8
so we don't take the rook if we take the
rook we do run into some trouble
with bishop to h2
so black can go knight h5 try and go for
a quick attack
or they can also play the thematic e5
break
which is a break that black is going to
try to go for to free up the position
this pawn i mentioned earlier is a
weakness on e6
so here black is just trying to trade it
off get it off the board
and open up this line for their bishop
here we normally see pawn takes knight
takes we see
a trait of knights in the center and now
bishop to g3 which is another reason why
bishop to h4 was played earlier
and here probably one of the best ways
to try and defend against this
threat on h2 is just go bishop g3 and
trade them off
and that's exactly what black does they
trade off on g3
queen goes to b6 introducing some
pressure queen to d2 defending
bishop to d7 and here we end up in
a i guess pseudo-end game where it's
pretty even white just has that you know
first move advantage and here this
isolated queen's pawn is a big target
so queen c7 is a line that
black can try to play can lead to some
more energetic positions with attacks on
the king's side
but if white survives probably a little
worse in the end game
um but queen b6 and queen c7 are not the
only moves here
the main line is castles just kind of
being flexible with your queen seeing
where it wants to go in the future
and we will see a nice bishop to f4 now
this idea
i've known from the exchange french
where white will take
on d5 and then try and go
knight e2 to go bishop f4 and trade off
the dark square bishops and the reason
why white would want to do that
is white's pawn here on d4 is on a dark
square
and with this pawn on a dark square
there's you know really no need okay i
should probably phrase that better
but um it's not like white needs to try
as hard to control the dark squares
if they have this bishop on the board
it's okay if they trade it off
and then what's going to happen is black
is going to be left with this light
square bishop and their pawns on light
squares and then white is going to have
this light square bishop and dark square
pawn in the center
and that's usually what you want your
bishop on the opposite color of your
pawns
that way your your bishop won't be
blocked in i'm sure there's better ways
to phrase that but hopefully that all
made sense
here we will see black trade and
knight to e4 which is a very nice move
this can be very sharp and here
it looks like white has two different
ways to play
first we will look at knight to e2 and
this is the line i was talking about
where there
is an exchange sacrifice on f3 and
it would do white well to just take it
because
it's it's the material you can't just
give away a knife for free
and after knight g5 we get a sharp
position that we'll jump right back into
but i do want to take a quick look at
queen to c1 because it is
shorter excuse me a shorter line we can
look through but
queen to c1 defending the knight we see
knight to g5
knight takes queen takes this knight is
attacked twice
but there is this very fun move here
bishop takes h7 check
if the king takes you have knight takes
e6
forking if the queen takes on
c1 here you have knight f8 check
after king g8 you take the queen they
take your knight and you have a material
imbalance here where
um white has was a rook and two pawns
for a knight in bishop
so black can be quick to generate
attacks because they have more
pieces but if you know white can always
defend against these attacks they may do
well because they have extra pawns that
can turn
into queens so that is a
pretty fun position that is equal for
both sides
but okay back to 92 there is this
exchange sacrifice
g takes f3 knight g5 and here
uh i believe the main move or probably
the most popular
is king to h1 now i do have a stockfish
13 here suggesting pawn to f4
and kicking the knight and then king g2
and then queen h4 but honestly these
lines looked um a little sketchy to me
for whites
they worried me as a player if i were
given these positions i'd be worried
about my king's safety
so i didn't look into them too much i
just focused more on king to h1 because
it looked like the king would be safer
and here we see pawn to e5
again that that nice break black has at
their disposal to open up the position
for their bishop to kind of trade off in
the center
it should be noted that taking on f3 is
a mistake
because of bishop h7 and if king
takes there is queen to d3 and white
will get a lot of activity they're going
to have all their pieces developed
you know this rook isn't really doing
anything in the corner so white will
enjoy a nice position
there if they go something like king to
f7
well white has just won a pawn on h7
um so back to e5
white normally takes and then black
takes on f3 first
this pawn on e5 is not going to be
protected by anything
soon so it's better just to go to f3 and
then hit e5
later if let's say they go knight e5
there's
knight g1 protecting f3 after queen f6
hitting it again bishop to e2 and it's
looking like white
is holding on so bishop to d7
good move if they go e6 trying to
protect the pawn
i have this marked as a slight mistake
due to queen d4
and now white is going to get more
development getting the queen active
but bishop d7 queen takes d5 king h8
and i have this marked as an unclear
position because even though white does
have developed pieces black does have
pieces that are out there
and you know taking on f3 may look
attractive after something like rook f8
and you just put everything on f3
so unclear position there
but knight takes f3 is the main move
we're going to look at
knight to g1 looking to trade off this
knight is attacked
twice so you cannot capture with your c
knight
you have to capture with your f knight
after knight f takes e5 bishop to c2
saving the bishop pawn to d4
and here we see where black has this
past pawn which is going to be
what they're playing for but
i mean white still has stuff here they
have some heavies i mean they're up
what is it in exchange for a pawn i
believe it's an exchange
and a for four upon where
you know again if white can survive they
should be better
but black does have this easy plan of
pushing this pawn down the d
file so you like bishop e4
bishop e6 and here i have an equal
position
okay i did mention that there was a very
fun sideline we are going to look at
um all the way back on move 9.
so back to move nine when f6 was played
uh we just went over e takes f6
which is the main move however uh one
very fun sideline popping up
is knight to f4
i really like this variation i know
other
youtubers have covered this move i know
that they prefer this variation too
and i guess one of the ideas here is
if they try something like queen to e7
trying to protect the e6 pawn
there's knight to f3 f takes e5
d takes e5 knight takes e5 we trade
knights on e5
and we end up with queen h5 check at the
end
where here after knight to f7 you can't
play pawn to g6 because you hang
knight so knight f7
white just castles pawn to g6 kicking
the queen out you have
queen to e2 hitting e6
pawn to a6 rook to e1
you know there's no no easy way for
black to save this pawn
after bishop g7 white can even take on
d5 because
if black takes there's mate so
very nice sideline here if they play
queen e7
however queen e7 is not the only move
here it is not forced
black can let this pawn just kind of
kind of sit there for now
and we see knight takes d4 this is
really the only move
for black here after taking
or sorry after nine of four they have to
take
so now we will see the critical move
pawn or sorry queen to
h5 you give up this pawn in the center
so you have to go for activity
if you don't go for activity you're
really just giving up a center pawn
which is a very important center pawn
because it was protecting e5
so queen h5 check and here g6
is a blunder for those of you who do
puzzle rush or puzzle storm
this is a very common tactical idea in
those kinds of tactics trainers is
knight takes g6 you're hitting the rook
and
if they move the rook out of the way you
have night checks for discoveries where
you're threatening mates
like this so
they take the knight and then you win
the rook
so they cannot go g6 not a good idea
here
which leaves the only move king e7
which may not be intuitive for some
people because you are blocking your
dark square bishop
here the critical continuation is ef6
knight takes f6 i just want to point out
that
it is a very bad move if black takes on
f6
with the king because of knight to d5
check and now if they take the knight
there's queen h4
and you pick up the queen
so that is why the knight takes it hits
the queen trying to get it out of here
and now we go knight to g6
this forking idea
now here black has to take the knight
with the pawn
um let's see what happens if they don't
if they
don't i believe queen h4 is the response
to all of them
except for king d7 it looks like so
against king d7 there's knight e5
check king c7 queen h4
knight to c6 looking to trade off the
knight
and then knight to f7 is going to hit
with you
winning an exchange uh the reason why
this would be
less favorable than losing the exchange
in the main line
is uh after age takes in queen takes
this queen is kind of
out of the game whereas in uh this line
with king to d7 and chasing it across
the board
the queen is still very much going to be
in the game
uh which is why this position will be
losing for black in the other position
equal
if they try and go king d6 queen e5 is
going to win the game
after something like king 2 c6 you can
just take on h8 with the knight
taking on d4 is also possible with the
queen
and if the king goes to e8s well here
there is queen h4
and you're getting ready to take on h8
so back to the main line they should
take because any king move
it leads to a losing position now queen
takes h8 and black is down the exchange
we go king to f7
just keeping an eye on all of our pieces
and is pretty safe actually it looks
like king the black king may not be safe
but white has no pieces really out there
to attack it
yes there is this bishop eyeing g6 but
other than that
really not much white can hit right away
we will see castles pawn to e5
again this break opening up the position
knight to b3 opening up the line for our
bishop
and black does well by trading off the
pieces
bishop to f5 again looking for trades
and bishop to g5 pinning also
looking to trade after a move like
bishop to c5
uh it's very important that white does
not go and trade the queens if they try
and
uh trade the queens black while in
exchange down
is doing better because of these center
pawns
and has a very easy plan of pushing them
all the way down the board
white does not want to allow black to
just get away with that plan
they want to keep up an attack so they
should go
queen to h3 moving it to safety keeping
an eye
on this f5 pawn black
should go queen d7 protecting this pawn
and after a trade we see king takes pawn
takes is also possible but it looks like
this
leaves white slightly better it looks
like they can try and get some play
on the c file bishop b6 and rook c3
are an idea doubling up but king takes
has been the most played move in this
position
and now rook f2e1 trying to get the
rooks into the game putting pressure on
these center pawns
that are very dangerous for white again
black is just going to try and push them
down the board
so we see something like queen e6 again
just trying to solidify all the pawns
and then we see pawn to b4
it is a blunder if black takes there is
bishop takes b4
runs into queen h for hanging the bishop
leaving white with a completely winning
position you can't be down in exchange
and a bishop
it's just not going to be great i guess
it would just be down a rook
so we see bishop to b6 and queen to h4
track and we'll see a lot of checking
here on the king side
with the queen trying to optimize the
position
white does have ideas of lifting the
rooks and bringing them over
but with good play black should just be
fine and not be in
too much of a worse position it's
white's gonna have to work really hard
to get an attack to work and again
black does have this pretty easy to
understand idea of pushing the pawns
all the way down the board
we do see the bishop come back to f6 to
block the check
you honestly can't block with the queen
and you can't just go
king down um because of stuff like rook
c1 and trying to take on g7
trying to you know skewer win the queen
so you see bishop f6 come back it's just
more solid
queen to h5 queen e7 we just see a bunch
of these
slow positional moves
and here is a pretty equal position
depending on what engine you ask it'll
say white's better by
plus you know half a pawn or plus a pawn
and a half
but i think practically this is
completely fine to play
definitely a very very fun sideline
for white that has been starting to pop
up more and more
and that is most of the theory there i
think that is everything in my notes
so we're going to open up the last 10
minutes here to any questions that the
chat may have
any line any position here in the
terrace french
i'll take any questions and we'll try
and get to the answer i'll scroll back
through see if anybody asked anything
earlier
okay we see the london popping up which
is
interesting
see some people are asking about one d4
these can pop up in one d4 if you play
one d4 black
plays pawn to e6
so let's see someone's asked about one
d4 i should just mention this is also
possible if after e6 you play pawn to e4
then it can transpose but most people
playing d4 on move one are going to play
c4 in which it's not going to resemble
most of these
positions
okay people are saying f3 or g4
i'm not sure what those are about
knight gf3 on what move ap
on what move make sure you add move
numbers that way i know
what where you're talking about here
the knight gf3 line there is no knight
gf3 line
although knight gf3 pops up in most of
these lines
in the last position
in the last position there was no knight
for white
we'll give ap a few seconds to figure
this out 3f3
i've never seen this move ever
it looks like it's been played by
masters three times but this is not the
torah variation
that's not what this lecture is over but
i'm curious about it
i think black can just take and then
play e5
or maybe not e5 but queen h4 check
doesn't look too fun i don't see how
you're going to
save e4 here
okay ap has some moves in the chat for
me so 184 e6 d4 d5 knight d2
knight f6 e5 knight d7
c3
wait knight fd7
c3 c5 knight g3 i'm going to assume
it's here with the knight on c6
and the knight going to f3
um so yes this is a position this was
one that we transposed from in one of
the sidelines let me see if i can find
what what line that was um
was it the morozovic no
actually it was where um
black just castles it looks like
let's see i'm pretty sure that's what it
was
unless it was it wasn't here with a
exchange
so i'm pretty sure it was just a that's
just another transposition from
to the marezovich line
what is my favorite line against the
tirash by sandro shak
um that's a very good question uh so
i normally play the sicilian dragon
against e4
and in those lines there's always a
thematic sacrifice on
on c3 where you sack a rook for the
night
so i really like this line in the closed
terrace
where let me see if i can find it where
did it go
it was the main line move 14.
we're on knight e2 black can just take
on
f3 and get this same sort of positional
sacrifice those kinds of moves in chess
are very appealing to me so i would have
to say
here in the main line after 92
this is my favorite variation
if it were white my favorite variation
would be the the knight f4 sideline that
we finished with
um but unfortunately you know white
doesn't have to play knight e2 here they
can play
queen to c1 where um you just had to
play knight g5
and trade trade it off and uh deal with
some of these nuances here on the king
side
but uh yeah thanks for the question
all right do you have any more questions
from the chat about any of the positions
we saw
tonight
give it 30 seconds and if i don't see
anything we're gonna
wrap it up here
okay dm is going back to that f3 line
again nothing to do with the terrash but
very interesting
um fe4 queen h4
king e2
bishop takes c3
there there is nothing on c3 i'm
confused now
oh i see i see um d takes e4
knight c3 bishop b4 i understand i
missed a move
here queen h4 king e2 um
so now the knight is protecting bishop
pawn pawn falls king f2
i don't even know what to say about this
position
no game found in the masters database
in the lee chess database has been
played about a hundred times in black
goes knight f6
bishop d3 queen goes to c6
now the engines are just saying black is
better
i'm inclined to believe it because
white's king
looks weird here but it looks like white
has survived most of these games and has
a plus score
so who knows maybe it's a practical
weapon this may be something to look at
for an openings lecture in the future
okay do we have anything else about the
tarash french if it's
not the torah i'm going to gonna have to
skip
over it we'll get to it another time but
uh
i think that's all it from chat so we're
gonna wrap it up here thanks for coming
to openings explained this was the
tarash french i'm nick risco again
thanks for stopping
by we're going to hop over onto twitch
and solve some tactics
i'll see you guys over there
you